[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Волинь
місто Соснівка]
Я просто відчуваю, що це моє покликання.
Я завжди знайду час на те, щоб прогулятися,
[Ігор Дзвіковський
музикант, місцевий активіст]
бо мені це подобається: мені подобається прибирати,
мені подобається, коли я ходжу, і ці стежки чисті.
Я відчуваю задоволення від цього.
Це мій стандартний маршрут в післяробочий час.
Я сюди забігаю, бігаю по лісу і збираю сміття.
При собі – все, що треба мати для плогінгу:
пара рукавичок і кульочок.
З цієї території я виніс десь порядку 30-40 мішків вже.
На початку тут взагалі все було засмічено,
але ми це все поприбирали.
Я бігаю, допоки не закінчиться мішок.
Коли він повний, і я вже бігти не зможу,
я його закидаю набік і йду на смітники виносити.
Не буває такого, що я зайшов з порожнім мішком
і вийшов з наполовину повним –
він завжди повністю забитий сміттям.
Плогінг – це новий вид тренувань.
Його придумав у 2016 році у Швеції
чоловік Ерік Армстронг.
Він помітив, коли бігав, що вулиці дуже засмічені.
І він подумав собі:
я буду прибирати вулиці, коли буду бігати.
І так воно в 2016 році зародилося у Швеції,
і вже через два роки, у 2018, просто розійшлося по всьому світу
і дісталося до нас, в Україну.
Я натрапив на відео, і мені
це так близько було, тому що я постійно цим лісом гуляю.
У мене назрівала ця думка, і я коли побачив це, я подумав,
що я мушу це робити, і десь понад 2-3 місяці
я стабільно бігаю декілька разів на тиждень.
До кожної пробіжки я прив'язую музичний супровід.
Я вибираю якийсь новий альбом якоїсь
музичної групи і під цей альбом бігаю.
Після кожної пробіжки
ти повинен зробити фотографію
або сміття, або селфі зі сміттям,
і викласти у соц. мережу.
Так воно швидше розійдеться по світу,
і більше людей про це дізнаються.
Тому, я веду невеличкий Instagram,
пощу фотографії зі сміттям,
пощу саундтреки, під які я бігаю,
і так відбувається.
Плогінг-спільнота є в Житомирі.
Дівчата вигадали там Плогофон:
це як марафон, тільки зі збором сміття.
Вони зробили в Житомирі, і тоді
я вирішив організувати його у нас в Соснівці.
Я розробив п'ять маршрутів, чотири з них – ходові,
ну тобто могли прийти діти, старші люди, ті, кому важче бігати,
але хто хоче допомогти.
Ми прибирали парк, прибирали школи,
а п'ятий маршрут був по периметру міста.
Довжина його 5 км, і вже найбільш рішучі
та витривалі залишилися на вечір.
Їх було небагато, але, я думаю, далі однозначно буде,
і буде брати участь більше людей.
Коли пластик викидають і він дуже довго лежить у лісі,
його потім просто не перероблять.
Тому що компанії, які приймають пластик, ставлять умови,
що пластикова пляшка має бути чистою.
Добре, щоб постійно хтось бігав і постійно прибирав.
Взагалі, мета цього проекту –
моя маленька мрія –
в тому, щоб плогінг общини були по всій Україні,
і в кожному місті стабільно
раз в декілька днів бігали люди
і прибирали якісь навколишні території, наприклад, ліси.
В місті менше проблем, тому що працює ЖК,
вони прибирають прибудинкові території.
А от в лісі ситуація найсумніша.
Воно все помаленьку розвивається.
Є люди, які приходять, допомагають.
Є ще ідея зробити ПлогФест в Соснівці
з великим плогофоном, з великим забігом.
Метою можна поставити збір коштів
на встановлення смітників.
Інформувати людей про те, що можна не купувати,
що можна купувати менше.
Я дуже радію, коли хтось проявляє ініціативу, каже:
«О, чувак, ти бігаєш лісом, я теж вирішив спробувати».
Для мене це найбільша похвала,
що хтось надихається цим, хтось теж це робить.
Я думаю, що воно повільно-повільно, але
все-одно іде на краще, якесь зернятко воно засіється,
і люди з часом побачать
і теж будуть робити це, будуть сортувати сміття.
За це можна отримати гроші
і таким чином ми можемо допомогти.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Ольга Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Субтитрувальник
Максим Сумець]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]